the electric state is a beautiful
nightmare
I don't know how else to describe it
I could say it's an art book by the
brilliant artist Simon stalinhog that
explores an alternate version of the
United States in the late 90s this is
true I could say it's a story where a
young woman in a small robot Venture
across a ruined landscape littered with
the skeletons of terrifying machines
this is also true
I could say it's a poignant warning of
how runaway consumerism can have
apocalyptic consequences this I believe
is true as well
yet none of these descriptions tells the
whole
so for this entry into the archive I'll
dive deep into this masterpiece of
sci-fi World building and like my video
on stalinhog's other series Tales From
The Loop you can purchase the art book
using the links in the description
now let's enter the world of the
electric state
the electric state begins in 1997 with a
mysterious girl and a strange yellow
robot venturing across the Mojave Desert
moving towards their distant destination
somewhere on the western coast much of
the electric state is centered around
their Journey Through the collapsing
Nation turning the narrative into a kind
of apocalyptic road trip this strange
Duo forms the emotional core of the art
book The Beating Heart of a world where
everything is increasingly mechanical
on the side of a Dusty Road in the
Mojave Desert clothes Blow from the roof
box of an empty sedan the car's owners
are now dried husks still dressed in
their vacation clothes a portrait of a
family vacation gone horribly awry
virtual reality headsets called neuro
casters still cling to their heads
likely the cause of their death
manufactured by the company Sentry neuro
casters are a reoccurring visual in the
electric State these face swallowing
devices were designed for military use
but soon became a common household item
as people lost themselves within a
blissful virtual Network
the side effects weren't noticed until
too late more and more consumers never
took their headsets off and would wither
away into lifeless shells their mouths
sometimes still moving as if trapped in
a dream
starts behind the eyes goes behind the
head my head is just getting tighter
the concept of people losing themselves
to a simulated nightmare is mirrored in
David cronenberg's existence a sci-fi
horror film that despite being released
in 1999 feels painfully modern like the
electric State existence is an
unsettling meditation on how technology
shapes and manipulates human beings
where virtual reality offers no
salvation but Oblivion
and in the electric State the
neurocasters proved to be quite
literally apocalyptic the exact cause of
the neurocaster's malfunction is unknown
but there are rumors that in connecting
so many brains through the headsets an
inter-cerebral intelligence emerged a
hive mind with an agenda of its own I
Feel clear-headed Again
finding a car and beginning a long drive
across California the girl and robot
witnessed The Surreal wreckage of a
collapsing civilization in one image
huge yellow ducks rise from the sand
like bizarre monuments their bodies
riddled with impacts from large caliber
rounds it seems the region was once some
kind of shooting range although it has
long been abandoned
elsewhere off the highway a giant metal
mascot of Roads away into a metal
skeleton its paint expression Frozen in
a permanent smile despite the
devastation surrounding it how the
animatronic reached its resting place is
left ambiguous although the framing of
the image makes it seem like this
machine walked here on its own
in a Dusty Town emptying of people
another machine sits in silence its body
a nightmare of Tangled wires there's a
fascinating incongruity between the
extraordinary Goliath and its ordinary
surroundings a fundamental
incompatibility that evokes a strange
sense of loneliness
yet at the same time there is something
undeniably threatening about these
childlike and cartoonish machines that
seem to appear more and more frequently
as the girl and robot creep ever closer
to their destination in these
illustrations stalinhag proves himself
an expert in The Uncanny creating
machines just abnormal enough to instill
uneasiness where these machines came
from and what they truly are is a
mystery that can only be solved by
venturing deeper into the electric state
wherever you are this summer could be a
very cool place
advertisements also Loom large over the
electric state in one Snapshot from this
post-apocalyptic road trip an immense
inflatable Sun smiles and throws up a
peace sign in bitterly amusing
dissonance to the end of the world in
another a giant heart-shaped mascot
rusts under the California Sun promoting
Financial Solutions for people with
terminal conditions the Macabre
juxtaposition between the upbeat
marketing and Grim subject matter is a
repeating Motif throughout stalinhog's
illustrations of advertisements a
reflection of a culture that pretended
everything was fine until it was too
late
on a passing billboard a slogan proudly
proclaims that neurocasters win both
Design Awards and Wars showing that
Warfare is seen as just another
opportunity for marketing and given the
devastation the neurocasters caused
there's a grim unspoken implication that
this advertisement would have been taken
down if there were anyone left to do so
where the electrical grid still
functions gargantuan towers of corporate
logos overshadow the homes of
residential neighborhoods these literal
monuments to suffocate in commercialism
cut through the fog with stalinhog's
exceptional eye for atmospheric lighting
making the scene particularly melancholy
cities like this Echo the visuals of
sci-fi films like Blade Runner whose
iconic setting is similarly Awash with
neon light from skyscraper-sized
advertisements
there's an undeniable familiarity to
these striking visuals the invasive
Billboards of the electric state in
Blade Runner or exaggerations but not by
much across the U.S how many Landscapes
are clogged with a mismatch of
commercial signs how many major cities
overload the senses with a blur of
fluorescent advertisements the United
States that the electric State depicts
is a nation seen through a cracked lens
where the specifics are distorted but
the overall impression remains
uncomfortably close to reality
one piece of media that can help us
better understand the electric State's
relationship to reality is the Sci-Fi
pixel art game Norco
released by Indie developer raw Fury in
2022 The Melancholy point-and-click
adventure takes place in an alternate
version of Norco Louisiana where
advancements in robotics and Industry
have created a land of desolation into
alienation
the urban sprawl of real world Norco has
been shaped by the petroleum industry
and has twice experienced catastrophic
explosions events that the game feels in
painful conversation with there are
moments where the pixel art Fades into
live-action footage of the region
blurring the line between fiction and
reality
like the electric state norco's vision
is both unfamiliar and recognizable a
long-lost acquaintance you come to
recognize the more you speak with them
this advanced technology helps to
diagnose arthritis but to effectively
relieve the minor pain of arthritis use
this
as the girl and robot continue their
Journey they spot crowds of people
wandering through Fields the red glow of
their neurocasters like Giant unblinking
Eyes these silent masses seem to no
longer have a will of their own having
themselves become drones piloted by a
mysterious intelligence in The Mists of
the western coast they work to assemble
a disturbing new class of machines
glimpses of these monstrous mechanical
beings appear throughout the electric
state in one piece a smiling face peers
out from the darkness of an abandoned
Barn something about the image pulls you
in making you curious about what the
rest of the creature looks like
later in the electric State we get a
better look at these incomprehensible
beings a Titanic drone looms over a
parking lot its face in raised arms
scavenge from an old advertisement
animatronic bundles of cables pour from
its head like the tentacles of an
octopus spilling down to the ground a
crowd of neurocaster controlled
onlookers watched the tentacles Slither
across the asphalt and into a parked
minivan witnesses to some dark ritual
while these Monsters of wire and steel
are nightmarish there is a quiet awe
that some of these pieces evoke like
wandering into the forest and coming
face to face with a gigantic animal
witnessing these beings can instill a
kind of dark Wonder in the viewer the
term Eldritch comes to mind a word used
to describe something otherworldly or
incomprehensible in this regard these
beings are reminiscent of the
unfathomably vast shambling terrors
glimpsed in films like the Mist which
instill a similar mix of dread and
wonder
stalinhog also experiments with light
and condensation in many of these scenes
creating portraits that feel like you're
looking through the rain-soaked window
of a car the Blurred light infused these
otherwise unsettling scenes with a kind
of nostalgia bringing you back to a time
spent looking up the car window as a
child watching the world distort through
droplets of rain in scenes like these it
almost seems like if you shut your eyes
the apocalyptic Devastation will fade
away
a massive neurocaster Network Tower
casts red light into the fog like a grim
Lighthouse making this region feel all
the more like a Gothic nightmare yet
Perhaps even more notably this section
of the electric state is set within
Marin County California the same region
as the 1995 sci-fi horror film Village
of the Damned directed by John Carpenter
the film tells the story of a group of
creepy children with creepier haircuts
who are connected to each other via a
hive mind a remake of a 1960 movie of
the same name both stories explore the
loss of humanity to a collective
intelligence a concept that is similarly
Central to the electric state
your family could take advantage of this
exciting new world like ours has
Pinnacle infection in the electric State
takes another less perceptible form
yellow service robots waddle across the
roads as the girl and robot Drive
onwards hauling massive cable rollers
these machines spread a dark network of
signal wires across the United States
connecting more and more regions to the
neurocaster hive mind
in the snowy mountains massive spherical
buildings serve as local hubs for the
neurocaster network their sides still
plastered with advertisements millions
of interconnected mines Bounce Around
inside each Hub the power required to
keep them trapped in a digital fantasy
melting the snow
while neurocasters never flooded the
consumer Market in our timeline there
was another network of interconnectivity
that became massively widespread in the
mid 90s the net can entertain you
transport you to far-off locations help
your children with their schoolwork and
make working at home easier the internet
and the neurocaster network reflect each
other with both connecting people in
incredible ways and leading to Serious
unforeseen consequences when viewed
through the lens of the internet the
dark network of the electric State feels
uncomfortably familiar with stories of
people losing themselves to a blissful
Oblivion and becoming dependent on a
digital net taking on new meaning why
you can even plan a family adventure on
the net
at various points in the electric State
the girl and the robot make rest stops
much like one would on any normal road
trip like real world liminal spaces
these near empty parking lots and motels
have an unsettling quality that is hard
to place there's a sense of time
crawling to a stop in these
illustrations which don't require
mechanical monsters to be unnerving yet
these narrative breaks also give the
storyline a chance to breathe and deepen
the viewer's understanding of the
protagonists the more you follow the
girl and the robot on their Journey the
more you empathize with their characters
stalinhawk does an outstanding job using
the minimal text in subtle visual cues
to demonstrate the bond that you have as
the world around them becomes
increasingly dangerous
in one of the most memorable points of
the voyage the girl in robot drive past
a forgotten war memorial a hillside
ravaged by bombs emerges from the clouds
two gargantuan military vessels simply
called drones sit in silent vigil Atop
The Hill a class of machines that played
a huge role in the backstory of the
electric state
while in the present of the electric
State drones are little more than
bloated metal carcasses these machines
once spearheaded the nation's military
in a nameless War these unmanned vessels
fought each other in a strategy game
played out over seven years though the
Drone technology was praised for
preventing meaningless loss of life the
collateral damage was catastrophic not
just in terms of Civilian casualties but
in terms of unforeseen technological
consequences for the drones were
controlled by pilots wearing Sentry
headsets with the wars spurring the
invention of the neurocaster technology
that would eventually go on to Doom the
nation it was supposed to protect
it's difficult to convey the sheer power
that stalinhog's art gives these
machines which feels so enormous they
become part of the landscape looming in
the distance like artificial mountains
in one image a drone seems to have been
converted into a makeshift dwelling with
a Californian flag and string of laundry
hung from its side
once trophies of Victory these colossal
wrecks are now bitter consolation prizes
a painful reminder that though the
nation one on one front the Triumph came
at the price of losing everything to a
mechanical nightmare
there is another narrative hidden within
the electric State running parallel to
the story of the girl in the robot is a
fragmented storyline of a mysterious
agent who seems to be headed towards the
same location
while their true Mission doesn't come to
light until the final pages of the
electric State the agent is a source of
constant tension as they seem to be on a
collision course with our protagonists
in the last stretch of the electric
State the girl and the robot arrive at
an overgrown childhood suburb that has
fallen to ruin in this final section
less and less text accompanies the
images with the breathtaking scenes
speaking for themselves
on the side of the road two figures
shamble through the night like nocturnal
animals towards the warm light of a
distant window at this point of the
electric State it's difficult to tell if
they're people wearing neuro casters or
entirely mechanical beings
bird-like drones called Scrappers pick
through the remains of this Coastal
Wasteland Laden with bags and bundles of
cables these artificial vultures work
tirelessly to collect mechanical Parts
perhaps for themselves or perhaps for
something else
above the overgrown Lawns of decaying
houses more colossal beings stand in
silence through dominion over this
region absolute in these suburbs where
families once lived machines are now
born from Twisted giant fetuses there's
a sense in these images that the plague
of machines has become a critical
infection and nothing will ever be the
same
yet the electric state is more than just
a story about hopelessness even at its
darkest moments there is always a faint
glimmer of humanity a spark of
compassion kept Alive by its two lead
characters
and everything builds to a resolution
that I found at once both unexpected and
perfectly in tune with the theme
stalinhog had established throughout the
rest of the volume while I don't think I
should give away all the specifics of
the electric State's final Pages if
you'd like to know more you can check
out the book for yourself
in the end the electric state is quite
literally a story that's as much about
the journey as it is the destination
what at first seems like an almost alien
world over time develops into something
uncomfortably familiar as the parallels
between the electric State's timeline
and our own become more and more
apparent
like Simon stalinhog's other most
well-known work Tales From The Loop it
is a haunting poignant book that pulls
you deeper into its atmospheric depths
the more you read and stays with you
long after the pages end
if you found this world as interesting
as I do you can purchase the art book
using the links below to get the full
story and follow Simon stalinhog on
social media
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious
see you in the next video